تطور جديد في قضيه ترامب
وسط انبائنا عن احتمال تحويلها من منهات
الى ستيتن الفريق القانوني لترامب يفكر
بالامر خوفا من عدم حصوله على محاكمه
عادله المحامون ما يزالون يقلبون الفكره
لكن لماذا استيتن اولا انما بين من هات
والستيتن ليس مجرد خليج يفصلهما
وانما قصه نصر في الانتخابات
بالنسبه لبايدن فان من هاتم هي التي حقق
فيها فوزا كاسحا في 2020 اما ستايتن فهي
التي تفوق فيها ترامب بهامش سبع وخمسين في
المئه اي ان فريق ترامب وبحسب المصادر
يعتقد انه سيجد محلفين محتملين اكثر وديه
وقالت مدعيه فيدراليه السابقه ان السبب
المعتاد للمطالبه بنقل المحاكمه دليل على
انه من المستحيل العثور على 12 محلفا
محيدا
مضيفه ان اي محاوله لنقل المكان من
المحتمل ان تفشل لان المتهمين لا يحق لهم
البحث عن هيئه محلفين بناء على خصائص
محدده يجدونها اكثر ملائمه